how do you keep the wheels of commerce
spinning when a pandemic slams on the
brakes
it's a problem the bicycle business has
been trying to fix since lockdowns
triggered a boom in demand
just as kovid 19 broke global supply
chains
every single humanitarian disaster has
resulted
in an upturn in the cycle industry every
single one
second world war first world war pearson
have been making bikes since 1860
but from factory shutdowns in asia to
the suez canal blockage
they've never faced a challenge like it
and prices inevitably rose
first of all it was complete bikes then
we had supply
uh issues around bike frames
uh some of which have stuck on the ever
given which you know
and then uh we've also had supply issues
in terms of componentry so gears and
brakes and that sort of thing
there has been a price increase now now
it's not something that we likely
pass on to the customer and we've
actually managed to absorb
quite a lot of the price increa
increases they haven't been price
increases because there was more demand
they've been prices
increases just because they were going
to be anyway no matter what
inflation is a hazard for all consumers
and the wider economic recovery but the
governor of the bank of england is
confident it will not run out of control
those things we fully expect to be
temporary
the world will come back to to more
normal
we do have there are things though we
are watching very carefully because i
want to emphasize that we don't take
this
lightly by any means we think it will
come back to target that's what we
expect
but we are watching labor shortages in
industries from transport to hospitality
are another factor in rising prices
but the bank thinks that even with more
than a million people still on
furlough unemployment has peaked we've
seen now quite a big abs
you know reabsorption of people on
furlough going back to their jobs
um so yeah we're the reason we're quite
confident is that you know that has
happened quite successfully so far and i
think it will but
the other thing i would say of course is
that even for those people who
unfortunately won't be able to go back
to the job they had
the rate of vacancies at the moment is
high so there are jobs out there to be
done
the road ahead is still uncertain the
bank says the continued spread of the
delta variant and the pandemic
have slowed growth but the worst may
be behind us paul kelso sky news at the
bank of england